i saw this video on friday shortly after
the show wrapped and i've just been
waiting for monday so that i if you
haven't seen it i could play it for you
and we can give this uh this gentleman
the credit he deserves so before we play
the clips here here's the post from the
the the headline from the new york post
says
store owner gets in heated exchange with
transgender woman over offensive sign
it's a defensive sign we're told that's
a many headlines saying that offensive
he's being offensive
and then we're told the owner of a
washington state star wars memorabilia
store got caught on video having a
shouting match with a transgender
politician who confronted him over a
sign in his window that said if you're
born with a penis you are not a chick
only they use the word for penis that
rhymes with uh with chick
if you're born with that you're not a
chick that's that's what the sign said
that's the offensive sign it's a
that that's that is
a plain fact
so this man already here's what we know
about this man
um he believes in the truth
and he's uh
he's an advocate for science education
because that's what that cited is
educating you on a
unavoidable fact of biological science
but the article goes on says thiessa
mesquez a council
woman quote unquote in the town of
aberdeen stormed into the sucher and
sons star wars shop and had words with
owner don sucher on wednesday over the
handwritten message that he posted
according to king five tv
um you could see and we'll play the
video here this is where the video picks
up
uh mescus comes in
is shouting at sucher saying trans women
are when women so on and so forth very
offended by the sign
and uh that's where the video picks up
and we'll play it right now here it
trans
is
trans women are women well i'm telling
you as a man that's [ __ ]
[Music]
it is it's totally okay you know what
nobody confronts you that's the problem
really if they'd say really what the you
want to bet what the
is you know
how many people you've embarrassed oh
city hall
me and they're harassment
city sir you are an embarrassment to
this
now you do that do you know why every
time somebody like this happens my sales
go up because people
are wanting this really really really
we're going to show them the side of you
and you do it you do it you do it really
good guess what we can wake you up
you are
not waking up you are not you're not a
woman you don't look like a woman you
don't act like a woman really
you're
in the head what's wrong with you
i am i am confronting you yes that you
are
oh man that is
uh this guy i want to adopt him as my
grand i want him to adopt me and be my
grandfather that's what i want
um and he's a and this is a the guy a
guy who owns a star wars memorabilia
shop i mean this is i i am finding unity
with someone who's a who's dedicated
their life to being a star wars fan
what does that tell you
and that's i i i unironically and i
don't even mean this as a joke i am dead
serious if i was president united states
i would give him the medal of freedom
and if it was up to me i'd nominate him
for a nobel peace prize i really would
because i of course am as fed up with
this as he is
and this is what i've been this is what
we're talking about talk about the last
week i always talk about it that this
this is the point people people need to
reach this point
where you're not going to cower and back
down someone comes in there and they get
in your face this offends me i don't
like it
i don't care
this is the truth it's just the truth
you're not gonna scare me and because
here's here's what makes this video so
refreshing
the the beginning part of it
we've seen that a million times
right we've seen it a million times
where someone in in with someone in the
protected class
and the most protected class of all is
quote unquote trans women
men who identify as women the most
protected of all
and once they have spoken
that is supposed to be the end of the
conversation
once they come along and say oh um what
you just said offends me then your
response is supposed to be well never
mind whatever i said it was wrong i'm so
sorry i beg for your forgiveness please
forgive me
and so
we've seen the beginning of the video
where the person comes in and confronts
and says this offends me
the rest of that is not usually how that
ends because usually the person who is
the offender the supposed offender then
they start then they collapse into a
puddle and they beg for forgiveness
and this guy just stands there and says
i don't care whatever
it's truth
you say you're a woman
you're wearing a dress
but you're not
you're not a woman you just aren't that
is not
true
uh it even gets better though another
quick clip here
as the as the confrontation moves from
inside the comic book or the member
sorry the memorabilia store and it goes
it spills outside and uh they continue
and this is where um the trans person
tells
our friend don that hey this really
hurts my feelings i don't i don't like
how this makes me feel what you're
saying
and here's uh don's response to that
let's watch and some people think it's
hurtful well told us that this hurt but
here's the thing i don't give about
feelings anymore i'm 70 am 8. i went to
vietnam to fight for all
do you think i care about some feelings
absolutely not
thank you sir
that's it
and this is especially what we need we
need
you know and i hate to say this i wish
that my generation or the younger
generations could stand up against that
but they're but unfortunately there are
so few of us that are that are that even
have our
our our heads screwed on correctly with
this
um
and in the younger generations i mean
they've been indoctrinated into this
from from from infancy so it's almost
hopeless what we really need
is sort of like the final service that
uh that that generation can perform for
us and they've done and perform many
other services
we really need them to just stand up and
say uh you know
i got nothing this is crazy i know it's
crazy i'm in my 70s
you know i'm not you know i'm i'm
reaching the end of my life here
eventually
and this is just nuts what do i got to
lose and that's this guy's added he's 78
as he says he's he's 70 bleeping eight
years old
what does he got what are you gonna take
from him
he runs a star wars shop
what do you have over his head
but you see even and that's how
pervasive this has become that even this
kind of altercation between a much older
person
who has lived they've lived their entire
life for the first you know this guy the
first 70 years of his life
there was no discussion at all about
whether or not a man in a dress is
actually a woman it was not even
discussed
we didn't talk about it
and then in his seventh decade all of a
sudden he's supposed to change what he
has known to be true for the past for
the previous seven decades
and at least he's willing to stand there
and say no you talk no you can't just
come along here and expect me to
after 78 years to abandon everything i
know about reality because of because
you're upset
and he's willing to say that but so many
people
this is not just a younger person
problem older people too
i mean this country is still being run
largely by people in their 70s
and they've all bought in
joe biden is 78 years old
and he's running he's you know he might
as well dye his hair pink at this point
running around south he for his his
rhetoric at 78 joe biden he sounds like
a 19 year old gender studies major
and that's the case for so many people
but at least here's one guy willing to
um
simply speak the simple truth it it's
it's
sad that
this is a notable event at all that i
got to spend that i'm spending 10
minutes talking about it
there should be nothing notable about
this whatsoever this is a rational guy
being confronted by an irrational person
and simply speaking some really basic
fundamental truth about reality
and that should be that
that should be there should be nothing
notable about that
but it is because there are so few
people
who are willing to do that these days
[Music]
so don sutra american hero
um let's make him president yeah we're
electing 78 year olds these days so why
not him
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content